so what'd you think about the fight on
sunday
uh
it's pretty good it's pretty good
what'd you think
oh yeah i mean i also thought it was
good i mean i thought the result you
know how it ended yeah was um you know
totally fine
i was fine with it what'd you think
oh yeah no it was
it was fine
it's totally
what'd you think
yeah i mean i totally thought that it
was a good fight totally fair
totally you know
fair i thought it was totally fair
i love the fight actually i thought it
was awesome dude it was so good how it
ended up
it was good it was good what'd you think
oh man yeah i loved it i [ __ ] loved
it
what did you think dude honestly i
thought it was so sick i thought it was
so [ __ ] sick dude what'd you think
about it
oh man
when i say i had a good [ __ ] time man
i had a really good time
what'd you think of the fight on sunday
[Laughter]
i loved it man yeah no what a awesome
what a stunning piece of entertainment
yeah i thought it was awesome yeah
um like
it's kind of like who [ __ ] cares yeah
but
it's uh it's it's annoying well you had
a good insight
uh before didn't you when we were
talking about it before would you say
oh well yeah okay so if we're talking
about the fight itself
the thing with tyron that you know was
gonna play in jake's favor is that
he
at a point
you know he that just became his fight
style it just became slower too
calculated and a lot of people criticize
him for not getting active and
he's done the same thing in mma that's
why you know he's struggled to win
rounds in like the later part of his mma
career because
he was way way too patient it just
didn't seem like
you know he didn't jump on logan he had
logan logan he had jake hurt like i
would say two times in the fight i felt
he he had him uh
scared yeah oh i mean that's why i
tweeted this updated status
retired boxer
so you're saying he's retired now
maybe
i mean maybe he's you know
maybe he's uh god that's so
yeah
yeah no he felt it
that that i know it's yeah it's annoying
that like he won on points or whatever
and you even afterward you know everyone
was like oh tyrone you're going out bad
like this and that you know and and
tyron's like let's run it back
that to me you know that was like promo
but that's also like tyron is a fighter
yeah so he's always gonna be down for
the most part yeah and as much as jake
jake tried to make it about other things
you know
it was so funny how like i'm bouncing
around here but the thing that really
annoys me about the two of them is
they're such snake oil salesmen like
they're such con artists like they're
sitting there 30 seconds prior
you know logan's going
i said my bro i lost my voice from
cheering so hard my brother you know he
tyron woodley's a a ufc welterweight
champion you know they're they're
coat like they're bigging up all his
accolades all those accomplishments and
combat sports and then tyron goes [ __ ]
you man let's run it back i [ __ ] i
had you scared and the thing that saved
you was the ropes let's do it again
because i'ma [ __ ] you up and what does
logan do you're old news fam
oh you talking about jake or logan in
the post fight okay sorry i'm talking
about post fight when they're asking
because logan is standing beside jake
and ariel helwani asked logan like oh
what do you think okay and i just that
was like the theme through the whole
promo it's like on one hand they
underscore all the all the great things
about tyron as a fighter and then then
they'll down him you know oh he's a
loser and this and that and
they're just such like their fan base
are people that hear the last thing they
say and that's what they echo and repeat
and they just have no [ __ ]
brain like there's no brain cells yeah
it just pisses me off like that's how
they get by yeah
kid throws out of you know throws out
some jabs like yeah in terms of boxing
he did win
you know he he was more active he had
more
i shouldn't be scored that way
especially no these fights that are like
exhibition fights it should be scored i
agree
who got the closest to getting knocked
out that person should lose i think
that's how a lot of people feel you know
unfortunately that's not how boxing is
scored but yeah like
any time
uh here's the thing i loved
and i wish people would pick up on this
in some capacity first of all
pre-fight logan's going i mean
tyron's gonna get knocked the [ __ ] out i
mean my brother's right hand is a cannon
dude it's a missile
no
didn't didn't do anything to tyrant it
landed a couple times didn't do [ __ ]
yeah and when you look at all the times
tyron got
popped his fighter instinct is there to
trade he got hit and he was immediately
throwing something back so
never did jake really stun him you know
that that right hand it wasn't nothing
and jake is heavier than tyron naturally
i believe right i think jake walks
around like
like over 200 and tyron you know fights
190 like i think he's kind of naturally
at his weight
so
everyone's saying oh jake's the bigger
dude tyron's not going to knock him out
tyra needs to be scared he's the smaller
guy blah blah blah it's like
jake is sitting there crossing his feet
like an amateur like because he is
and
i i don't know after after like rounds
one and two he was just running yeah
throwing little hands out in there he
had a couple good combos but he never
did any real damage though no never
looked like he was in trouble no this
moment right here yeah it looked like
jake was in big trouble yeah
yeah and and a slightly more competent
boxer
you know
the way i see it even though tyron's um
tyron's
uh
nature is to be a bit more like
conservative as far as fighting i feel
that it's natural that he kind of just
like stayed in the center and stayed on
a single line like moving back and forth
because he's just learned how to box
so like his footwork isn't going to be
totally there so i feel even in the
moments where he had jake in trouble
maybe he just didn't have all the tools
like to know how to like step forward
and like be confident to like oh i could
i could put him away right here yeah i
don't know why he didn't do that
especially in this moment right here
it's like attack
he's he's that's the problem he does he
did that in mma and that's why it's so
it was ideal for jake because jake got
those moments to rest but a slightly
more competent boxer with his with
tyron's power
would put jake away like me or you would
have like in that scenario we would have
we would have been way better we would i
mean we would have like pushed forward
with attacked we definitely would have
finished the job oh 100 like there's two
guys watching from our couches yeah and
like with the pockets why did he just
attack like i would have yeah in that
situation why didn't he just kill him
right there yeah like for example i
would have done that mm-hmm that's what
something i i would have done and i
would have thought of that in the moment
and then done it absolutely yeah and the
fact that he didn't it made just me feel
like a little bit better of a boxer than
him i would have done that in the moment
oh yeah no like as someone who uh eats
three meals a day
right like i definitely would have had
the sense and really the skill set
to go forward and like get the dub yes
yeah yeah no that's true and like for me
as a former athlete
um you know 2008 olympic trials
12th
you know someone like that you know with
that sort of athletic mindset you know
it's used to pressure performing under
pressure especially
in that scenario i would have you know
kind of kept attacking you would have
knocked his ass out no you for sure
would have won
you know as a guy who like
works out three to four days a week yeah
i think i would have did a way better
job yeah
way more fight iq as a dude who's never
even sparred before right i have a
pretty good idea of how to win that
fight yeah yeah
coming from someone who's really good at
watching fights yeah actually i'm not
even that good of a watcher of fights
middle of the road
i think i would have known what to do in
that situation 100 yeah yeah
i think that's the thing that frustrates
me the most is
everyone thinks because
jake got a few combos in
he's like oh you know
he's like kind of like deserving of all
this respect even people i i know that
like boxing
are like coming around on it being like
hey man he went in there he did his
thing i'm like [ __ ] him bro he only
likes boxing as much as it makes him
money yeah so that's that's the point i
think that's why he said retired
was that was he talking about himself
there
maybe he was talking about tyron i mean
that's the best move he could possibly
do right now though of course he made
like 50 million bucks off this [ __ ] this
year alone yeah he's done and then he's
just gonna be like he got scared clearly
he's like i don't have it so i'm just
gonna retire right now yeah with a
winning with a undefeated record i mean
that's so annoying he just yeah
he just no you know he just he just gets
away with it the other thing that
i've said before that i didn't have like
a ton of confidence saying but i feel a
lot of a lot more confidence saying now
is
he
like tyron's 39 you know like he's older
and he should be slower he should be
like his age should show a little bit
tyron's hand speed was like six times
jake's jake's hand speed looks so dog
[ __ ] and granny he's like he's not he's
just begun like began boxing but i say
that to say
he doesn't show like
how do people not look at him and see oh
this is a guy like just learning how to
do it he's not like some stellar athlete
he doesn't have like some x factor he
doesn't go in there and like move really
clever and he's like really a really
special athlete in there he's like no
he's just big and he kind of lumbered
around and he weathered the storm and
it's like that's worthy of all this
[ __ ] like oh man
jake paul is a tough guy it's like
is he yeah i don't know man
i you know i would have got cleaned from
that hit by tyron so maybe i have no
place to talk no we wouldn't have
no no you're right yeah no as someone
who eats carbs in every single meal
for every meal yeah if someone who eats
carbs
the entirety of the meal is carbs every
meal of the day
i think i could have taken that punch
and not been knocked out yeah and in
fact won the fight
yes as someone who
uh
has ridden a bike before
i probably could have taken that hit
pretty easy
yeah i just would have rolled with it
yeah you know because dude like i've
i've ridden bikes i've been on the
subway before i've taken the bus yeah
those are all things that prepare you
for a moment like that totally 100 yeah
yeah i wear pants most people you know
don't like wearing pants i wear pants
sometimes
yep and i think that you know just that
mentality i have like to wear pants if
tyrone would hit me with that shot i've
been like dude
i wear pants like almost every day like
right
in 80 degrees i know what you're saying
i personally like as someone who
did the stairmaster yesterday for 15
minutes
like without stopping either yeah so
it's like straight through that's crazy
level 10 too wow
it's pretty fast yeah there's someone
who could do that
like i could see myself getting in the
ring and just kind of winning yeah
so
yeah jake honestly should retire because
like
you know after that like horrible
performance he put on it just made me
think like obviously we'd go in there
and win
yeah
so like when we start boxing like he
definitely doesn't want to see us in
there no
no
yeah
a good good choice bro good choice yeah
get out while you still can yeah because
shit's about to get shut down once we're
in there bro yeah dude
it's gonna be crazy when people sign up
to fight us not realizing it's two
versus one
yeah we tag each other in like wrestling
stuff no no we're both in there okay
yeah yeah okay like one of us is
standing and they're like oh one on one
and then the other one jumps in it's
like wait a second it's like yeah
it's a twofer yeah it's a bogo no we're
on each other's shoulders yeah trench
coat yeah
put them up so we look like we're
you know five people 10 feet
10 feet tall put up your dukes yeah
come on